all right don't you don't you feel like
given your druthers wouldn't you have
rather have had more sex in your life
than you have up until this point I know
you on the other hand I had a lot of fun
that [ __ ] everything and everybody by
age 30 I did not by age 30 but just by
age 40 it's just there was an awful lot
of time and energy invested in sex for
me when I was throughout the majority of
my life so you like over it now not over
it but it's it's it has its tapered off
a little bit it's a little more
manageable now it's not quite as
all-consuming I got other things that I
think old man look at my life I was once
like you were for me that the difference
was pre and post kid my kid now takes up
so much more focus and energy in terms
of her well-being that I'm less selfish
about my needs and wants and desires and
something that was the shift that's
weird
like if you have to put a number see
this game is not a winning thing because
rough guest:i me write down my answer
Alex Final Jeopardy I'm gonna walk you
through it ready four figures
no no I'm not [ __ ] Wilt Chamberlain
for [ __ ] sake
alright three figures three figures yeah
three numerical figures yes yes okay mid
three figures em mid no no probably I
mean it would be five hundred right no
less than five hundred yeah less than
four hundred yes less than I'll just
tell you the number if you [ __ ] know
the number no I stopped I used to make a
list see again
again I tell you I was preoccupied I was
pissed
well wouldn't you want to know everyone
you ever had sex with I do you know
everyone you ever see I do there's only
like [ __ ] 3334 wouldn't you want to
know what wouldn't you hate it if there
were people out there you had sex with
and you couldn't remember their names
that would never happen I don't think
but you wouldn't want that to happen
would you so after a certain number you
guys start writing them down you're
gonna forget a few I guess that's true I
don't know if I couldn't keep up to 200
300 names you can't trust me and did you
like this wasn't like you dated them all
some was like yeah they're all long
important relationships in my life
doesn't so some were just like hi I'm
Ralph I'm Sally really you're wasting
time with names you think that's what's
happening all right so what was your
number you think I stopped the list at
200 it's not an applauding thing it's
not about applause or not applause just
makes me feel like I wasted my whole
life you didn't you build a career yeah
but who gives a [ __ ] bad you stopped
counting at 200 I thought that I said
this is getting to be tires this is this
is gonna be work now I gotta write down
everything and keep a list I said [ __ ]
then I'm just gonna live my life I let
it go all right so you stopped counting
at 200 yeah do you think you got over
300 probably not do you got 250 probably
what do you have to remember I was in
the swinging lifestyle and stuff and
everything I do and threw on all that
stuff so it's just it's it's a little
it's a lot of activity if you're in the
swinging lifestyle do you have sex every
day of the week
why not because you have to get a job to
pay the rent and things have to be done
and you gotta get gas and you have to
you know go to work and stuff so then
how many days a week would you would you
swing I don't know probably just
weekends so two days a week what is the
we do include three no probably Friday
and Saturday nights maybe you want maybe
both maybe want just one of those on the
weekend and all week long were you're
like then sometimes like a convention I
got like a weekend like a like a Vegas
three or four day weekend convention
thing and then you do it every every day
all day what the [ __ ] was that like this
is a conversation for another show we've
got we're all fascinated by this man
[ __ ] celebrities this is the news oh
it's not it's just it's just it's just
no fair enough all right
what Oh read my book
[Music]